[Music]
with six weeks into my nationwide
restaurant competition and so far I
found my best Italian restaurant
castamere from Bristol my best Indian
Prashad from Bradford my best Chinese
you and you in Blackburn my best British
the milestone in Sheffield and my best
Thai restaurant naam Jim Thompson Andrew
Steele tonight we'll see who'll be
joining them in the semi-finals from
your favorite French restaurants can be
I'm expecting tonight's contenders
deliver something really special where
the please please Lisa thank you talk to
any Frenchman he'll tell you they have
the best Russians in the world with a
lots of British restaurants serving
great French food for centuries French
restaurants have set the standards of
the dining room as well as in the
kitchen a good French restaurant will
where you with the elegance and the
sophistication of its service as well as
its food from nearly a thousand
nominations I've chosen two brilliant
French restaurants to battle it out
replacing my semi-finals wenjian fields
in Lincolnshire served stunningly
complex fine-dining dishes so beauty
presented it takes your breath away
Dorie away please where we know
wintering fields we live it we breathe
it and it is that nice place where you
can sit down and be treated like a king
for a knife baton against them Edinburgh
sliggoo each headed up by a Gallic
gastronome who wow these diners with
simple rustic dishes bursting with
flavor
- got cheese - micro - sea bass - beef
make it snappy please I'm not cooking
for kings I'm cooking for simple games
like me for country boys but my French
restaurants are about to face three
formidable challenges designed to put
them under extreme pressure
first off I've deployed an army of 30
hungry customers who'll invade each
restaurant in turn and all order at once
they're on their way to sample the food
on offer at the 16th century manor house
an estate at winching and fields in
Lincolnshire
what I like most about this place is
it's it's quaint and it's like a little
mini oasis and also they depend on the
local ingredients stuff produced on
their doorstep and they turn that into
the most amazing food hi guys I've
forgotten how beautiful this place is
amazing amazing amazing five years ago
husband and wife team Colin and Bette
put everything they had into this
stunning restaurant Bob Beck tastes care
in front of house
Colin heads up the kitchen service piece
wait ten minutes he creates exciting
modern dishes capturing all the
fantastic flavors of great French
cuisine without the heaviness lobster
risotto I'm excited about this delicious
Collins pulling out all the stops to put
this place on the map the restaurant
boasts a five grand champagne on the
menu one waiter for every two customers
and even has its own helicopter pad
this is the the landing facilities for
the restaurant we give them the
coordinates and then we just pick them
up yeah they've got all the staff all
the gear the most amazing kitchen
there's obviously a lot riding on this
you'll see it on Colin's face he's under
pressure big time it is on the five
minutes from now then my diners will be
here and there are so excited about
walking into winter and fields and been
blown away you have dedicated your life
to get this place right really make this
count
big test today two hours 30 of my diners
two courses make sure they leave on
cloud nine good luck my thirty guests
are all looking forward to being treated
and fed like royalty should be a doddle
pushy together on the pass you know
the sumptuous dining room screams luxury
for you Colleen quickly serves an
amuse-bouche not only will it prepare my
guests for the meal ahead but it also
shows off Colin's expansive approach to
cooking but it's not the only thing
that's expensive after you left the
appetizers he didn't collect the menu
which are quite big can't really place
it anywhere what is that I was like this
is your life ah only now st. Andrews to
pop out on the whole fireplace we're
away she's after the first amuse-bouche
come to another carrot mousse with
coriander ice cream anything a mistress
let's see how well you have time to get
two appetizers and two courses in Jesus
you don't do things by half dude there's
a lot going on you know honestly
sometimes less is more
they're delicious but it was quite a lot
of flavors to be served before you
actually did main meal perhaps maybe
just one would have been enough I admire
Colin's Eiffel Tower sized ambitions to
provide a stunning gastronomic
experience but the minutes are ticking
by and the theatrics show no sign of
giving way to proper food I'm gonna see
a red trolley outside the Humber Bridge
it's only big enough for Tony for but
yeah I just watch the waiter push your
bile is like banging left to right it
was a lot of words the sliced bread at
the same one adds to the face Robin set
30 minutes have gone and we haven't even
taken orders yes I'm not a foo-foo man
on the flavors man and I want this food
I gotta have the kitchen when they get
to taste this food blown away at last
orders I've been taken college men you
would do any French gourmet proud it
includes paper fried Cory's bream with
muscle and saffron fricassee a beautiful
ham hock of foie gras terrine and one of
my favorites John Dory sir with a burger
ham and an ollie past sauce
yeah what's this also again the
fricassee of muscles of Shreyas room
very testing they like the food go down
a storm but it's overshadowed by the
service
[Music]
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven
buuut anymore look who are you guys
there seems to be an awful lot of people
I don't think I've got any more than the
reson here just check there's no one in
here no I was in the same person's voice
yet now free front of house managers and
twelve other waiting staff what are you
doing for service until curfew
no excellent came out this is in
Heathrow function just for the stuff
Colin that's one hour got one hour to go
yes for his mains Colin is showcasing
his unique take on the glorious French
tradition of fine dining he's serving a
delicious rolled saddle of lamb with
polenta chicken cannelloni with foie
gras and an opulent lobster risotto
accompanied by a parmesan twill and
lobster bisque
please the food looks amazing but the
table management system is chaotic with
too many people involved it would be so
much better if just one person took
responsibility the status mains desserts
and then we have a little appetizer tic
basically the chef can see it from where
he is and everybody up here knows where
they are up here I'm not convinced
despite all the waiting staff those
restaurants letting my diners down
we went through a course yes
yeah Maddy started oh yeah we've got
confused and left us a little bit okay
so just one hour 20 minutes with nothing
in front of them all these waiters are
flying around no starters look better
than that - dorri - brain is away now as
time ticks on everything started to get
muddled up we'll stay with you one last
they will fall and the full scale of the
mess is only just becoming clear ever
fought here just had before are you saw
your saucers little over an hour and a
half now our starter wants to play with
know start watching everybody else yeah
how far is that way
unfortunately someone crossed they asked
for this huh
how can you have so many management out
there and they cross it off and they've
even send them yet huh they've got more
managers here they've got a pumpkin
palace - keep going keep going keep
going with time running out fast and
some guests still not served I'm
starting to fear the worst
I say that's it twenty minutes to go
coming mister get there by the skin of
our army chicken sauce Amy chicken sauce
my five minutes percent [ __ ] let's
get it out three waiters guys passing
[Music]
don't someone help him to the ice-cream
puts garnish on it you know but then I
see the problem is she put me if giving
me that which is Table four and Table
six right
I said timeout two hours gone incredibly
for the first time in this competition
and not all my diners been fed two
courses for a restaurant this good it's
embarrassing do I want to be judged on a
dish wazzle do I want to have that serve
in front of me oh it's a no-brainer
it's beautiful I mean just stunning they
can't tell everybody how [ __ ]
delicious because it stopped after two
hours the only comfort for Colin is the
fact that the diners that did receive
their food loved it there was nice as
well worth waiting for
well worth watching fun we did wait a
little longer than expected and when it
can yeah well with end of service and
time for me to tell winterim feels
whether I thought things were bomb or
not big tests see back from the dining
room service claustrophobic that's what
I pulled some of the waiters out and get
rid of some of the drapes I think you
know that kind of the stayed you
winching them fields esque service can
look I mean great feedback back from the
customers their experience the service
being too claustrophobic yeah she
listened to ignore it ignore it
are you peril if my diners felt that
your service was claustrophobic
please listen to it because it's
valuable information we're looking for
the best restaurant in Britain not just
for the best food but the best service
and it goes hand in glove the customers
loved the food which is great news
sadly then get chance to taste it all
because we ran out of time don't worry
about the foo-foo I think you guys try
too hard and I just think you guys just
need to chill a minute you match the
service with a level of attention to
detail on the food
you've got something unique here I'm
looking for the nation's best French
restaurants and your nominations have
led me to a fantastic place in Edinburgh
one of the best French restaurants in
Scotland are definitely contender in
this competition I fell in love with
French fruit from a very early age so my
standards already high and tonight I'm
hoping to be inspired by this amazing
little Bistro where's the French man
where's he hiding little dungeon yeah
yeah good to see this is your sous chef
Mia wow I can see two head chef
jean-michel
has spent his whole life cooking in
high-end French restaurants but a decade
ago he turned his back on the world of
exclusive port cuisine to open his own
restaurant serving no-nonsense no-frills
French rustic fair Romania definitely
the style of cooking I wanted to do was
totally different nothing to do with was
being done actually in restaurant
nowadays that's the come from here from
the heart is great I'm not cooking for
kings I'm cooking for popper I will give
a simple guys like me for country boys
jean-michel and sous chef Yanni server
favors like delicious pan-fried scallops
The Bistro classic twice-baked rock for
souffle and rabbit rillette this
award-winning Bistro has earned its
loyal following yeah that's nice texture
that delicious lemony he walked through
the door of the gallery you really feel
like you're back in France and that's
one of the biggest compliments I can pay
a Frenchman there again with food this
good
combined with Jean Michels bonhomie
surely miCoach diners can't fail to be
seduced
you can do it lead the kitchen drive the
kitchen yeah run the dining room give
some French charm to the service some of
the guess will come in and think that
the rabbit is a little bit intimidating
explain some shots in love with Lipan
and he adores rabbit and more
importantly sell it more shots
[Music]
restaurant manager Julie and are all
French front of house team wastes no
time in lane on the charm is for you
it's spring onions and cheese panics
thanks make it up for you thank you
how's the menu sounds absolutely
enticing enticing if you have any
question about those rabbits as a cook
no problem okay so I'm out to rabbit one
meringue one brioche orders are started
come in thick and fast Julie the team
have done a great job of selling the
rabbit already have six yes however a
French one happy I was happy
jean-michel Oh Julie have a unique
system of communicating service Julie do
you want me to tell you when you're
ready for the stuff there's in the main
course just by what we do the when I ban
she comes when you bang she comes sounds
like a porn movie
how was a real virtually the atmosphere
upstairs is buzzy and relaxed and my
diners love the food curse but the
kitchen is far too relaxed from I like
him and there are some silly mistakes
occurring so Misha is that the rabbits
flying out ah let's go put the students
a lot of minutes chef
the most popular dish tonight is the
saddle of rabbit with black pudding and
Apple that's good to go yeah the meats
wrapped in fat to base the rabbit as it
cooks it's great to see John Michell
using such a traditional technique but
I'm worried about how he's running his
kitchen the board is full of checks
you're halfway there yes this is where
we're right up against it right now
jean-michel doesn't seem to be taking
the lead in the kitchen leaving both his
Brigade and front-of-house team
rudderless can't get away from the stove
this one Kenny joy was it once he gets
gone that sir
I know he loves cooking but with so many
orders on at the same time someone needs
to be taking control are you supposed to
read his mind cousin talk to try oh sure
the rabbit's been left under the lights
on the hot plate for two minutes while
jean-michel plates up the lamb that
rabbit goes dry within 30 seconds
they're such a shame
Joey I say this is what hurts for me
doing you've gone from a chef into a
cook in the language not ready in the
rabbits and in their hands just look at
me two seconds he's gone silent ninja
poison and otherwise it'll be the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
that's my one ingredient I'm missing
sugar is a leader I'm not saying it to
make you look stupid
I'm not turning at the food out at the
same time I it's not mine it's not my
kitchen so when the rabbit sits there
for two minutes and Yelling's looking at
you waiting for a call I just needs a
leader two three minutes on a pond or
food please such a shame
Jean Michels gone from the owner now
into a cook because he's not talking to
anybody
next we go Paul share one fish two lamb
one rabbit thankfully yummy as family's
voices sort of started holding the reins
because this place needs an organizer
and someone as a front runner I love the
way Yanni is tasting everything he's
proven to be the rock in the kitchen
tonight hold on to second object object
we're not back please I'm not asking
just [ __ ] on your boss yeah oh yes he's
standing there slicing the [ __ ]
rabbit it's gone dry there's two lamb to
be plated up and he's not saying thing
to you right next you cook [ __ ]
amazing food yeah but I don't understand
why you disappear in service when you
you don't talk to anybody so I'm just
struggling to identify who is the leader
tonight yeah yeah I want to find the
best restaurant in Britain and the best
racer in Britain doesn't have food that
sits on the hot plate for two nine three
minutes
we're on to desserts always a highlight
of great French cuisine true to form
Jean Michels created simple rustic
desserts including brioche pan perdu
with apricots Julie I'm so sorry but the
chef check that this [ __ ] Jews run
out with them well when it's busy like
that okay he's not busy zone two tickets
left please show him the dessert a
cursory glance just doesn't do it
we should have tasted them okay they
because unripe and they should never be
used in the first place that's why as a
chef seen them an hour ago we miss
nothing going at a kitchen whether
you're running a bistro fine dining or a
burger school you watch everything damn
what a shame
I maybe there's a point there with a
really dessert I think that the
separatists could have been much better
[Music]
there have been serious mistakes in the
kitchen tonight but what's the verdict
front of house it's delicious here's a
freshly my favorite toy driver and it's
nothing special is there a really meaty
for some party yeah I love that it's
fantastic Kirsten it's time for me to
tell the guy exactly what I think
tough night bite off every restaurant in
every category is going under that level
of scrutiny it's pressure test we know
our chefs that food shouldn't hang for a
long time on the hot place I know they
have to think the blade for it that
shoot ups the other path said and they
did it because I know they can do the
job well I did love downstairs was how
often was tasting stuff so when you run
upstairs with apricots that the chef
hasn't tasted I'm not sure to come back
down and if you tasted those apricots
before they left the hot plate I
guarantee you I said stop we're not
serving the pan perdu with apricots
apart from that friendly service bloody
good food they do thanks very much the
giri's got great potential but it has to
be consistent on every plate whether
it's the most amazing starter or a
phenomenal dessert it has to be that
exact standard across every plate and
jean-michel has to decide if he wants to
cook all night long and pass the leaves
you qualities to his number two and if
he wants to lead then lean if wants to
cook then cook
[Applause]
[Music]
the coach trip was a massive challenge
for winter Phil's and lagari now I'm
providing both teams to London to
discuss how they getting on in the
competition but what they don't know is
that secret diners sent by me have been
to their restaurants the first is
brushed and critic Simon Davies I've
rigged him with secret cameras and asked
him to be demanding and difficult I'm
allergic to those I can't eat salt
honest now we'll really see how these
restaurants perform when I'm not there
watching and so will they first to see
the evidence is Colin from Windham
fields and his sous-chef Slavik how are
you big test for you wasn't it very
never done something like that before so
yeah any comfort zone unknown to you
you've actually been tested twice I sent
in my secret diner and this is what
happened on the coach trip they let my
diners down with over fussy food and
service but have they learned from the
mistakes hi that is for your vichyssoise
with some micro bath and other food
thank you very much thank you thank you
no we didn't ask for these they doesn't
change this first off great welcome and
these bushes are rising the table didn't
ask them gets put down and bang they
start eating you refined 3d front the
news but only two are available you have
the very first one which is the lunch
for you
and if you turn the page over you'll see
a red ribbon on the right of the red
with and you see the minutiae piece
that's the one that we only do in the
evening I can't be with this graphic on
the left hand side that however you'll
find the other cut which is fully
available as when we started and make
horses and then you'll find the deserts
at the back of the ownership is in the
following page the menus big imposing
choose descriptions as long windows to
get heavier and heavier and heavier and
they just want to be left alone you know
that the news fish that's three things
you've had so far that we hadn't ordered
know begin to feel like I've really
started to eat now I don't we haven't
had the first of our three courses
I hope it's another memories fish
otherwise I will be uneme fish one is a
really nice gesture great opener sets
the tone for what's happening next but
any more than one and it looks like
you're trying too hard
roasted Lobster that's when the lobster
risotto co-star it was a bansuri was a
soy pigment and it was a lobster mist
and the side the traffic laws oh yeah
some Parmesan cheese when he pointed out
rushon I swear this finger is actually
touched the motion we've not touched it
I don't know that's all I don't want
someone coming in that's that that's
that agri-food is exquisite you need to
look at your service you need to really
just rein that in and bring a breath of
fresh air in there and you'll surprise
yourself and more importantly attract a
different lion tower which you'd be
slightly nervous of going for let's go
it was great to get feedback from Gordon
it was great for him to say to me yeah I
mean it's good rounds of telling you
what's great about your cooking what's
not so good about it and and what to fix
about it and anyone who can say negative
things about it is great because that
means we can analyze it work it do we
need to change it it's great feedback
you know it is priceless
[Music]
refined French restaurant winter
gamfield from Lincolnshire service pace
it's been wait a minute is battling out
with Edinburgh charming Bistro leg young
age to become my best French restaurant
leg of each team jean-michel Danni and
Julie are about to discover that one of
my spies has been checking them out I
sent in expert food consultant and
CooCoo writer Sarah Durden Robertson she
knows what makes a great restaurant
hello hello hello thank you so much for
coming
that was a tough test what you didn't
know is that you've actually been tested
twice when I left the guy I sent in a
secret diner let's watch it shall we
my 30 dinars lovely quahogs rustic charm
but a service and food suffers from John
Michele's lack of leadership in the
kitchen are things running more smoothly
now
when I came out I said I was really
hungry yes I told the chef that you want
hungry
nice liaison between the kitchen and the
restaurant good he's actually very hot
in here even the boss is beginning to
melt and go soft hot outside doesn't
understand why it's so hot oh my
goodness thank you oh I'd be delighted
it's so hot the man with the power oh
yes are we not allowed to have that one
in the morning to get the rest of nice
and cool when butter starts melting on
the table are you cutting back on the
electricity bill good they live just for
good - pretty good or there's a bit of a
schoolboy error when we can't have the
air conditioning on well shame
is it too late okay I just have boil
impetuses please anticipate I just don't
world - okay thank you
things are delicious a lot like watching
the Internet is that yeah if that's okay
yes okay yeah thank you
she's bombing my placement potatoes
[Music]
potato pone and he's not a finalist
I'm talking about the horrible greasy
set of potatoes that came out something
in fat they look dreadful in the kitchen
guest appeared to be more energy to
watch over than yeah you can't do
everything change everything I know you
can't but when you cook a stunning main
course the garnish is he can support us
it boils down to the consistency again
doesn't it what a shame
why are you not gonna make it yep ok so
anyway we could take these in a doggie
bag
oh not the ice cream obviously cuz I
just think we're not gonna make their
flight in time otherwise sorry that's my
fault
thank you very much it's lame
[Music]
Idina were in a rush now we're ready to
go waiting for to come take the money
she's on to the phone he's gone on to
the kitchen she still hasn't come to
take the money the Shane right at the
very end dying to catch the flight it's
an urgent request and it's just been
blamele ignored so it was like some of
small little niggling facts that you put
them all together it's like a bit of a
blow pop performance when I know when
that ration is on song it's the best
bistro in the country
[Music]
in a way I'm disappointed by the the
potato saga that has something that's a
lack of concentration the lack of
supervision with the service best thing
we can change cooking the potatoes the
communication with the shapes of the
scanner thing can easily be resolved
both restaurants have struggled this is
their last chance to impress me
I'm taking the chef's out of their
kitchens and into mine at my three
Michelin star restaurant in London where
I'm challenging them to create one
mind-blowing dish
I feel very confident we're a very very
strong team so we are going to work it
off bollocks off and it's gonna be you
know hopefully a three mr. star result
[Music]
Wow to be in this restaurant in this
kitchen today is a hell of an experience
we hope to win it I want them to raise
their game and cook like they've never
cooked before this is it the Battle of
the French within these four walls
there's everything I've ever wanted ever
work for and I suppose my dream come
true there's no greater platform for
both these restaurant today
the show-off only one restaurant going
through the semi-final make sure it's
you and every time you put food onto
that plate think semi final and good
luck all the best guys
French cuisine is close to my heart so I
can't wait to see what John Michell and
Colleen create using fish as their main
ingredient first table on the couch for
couples way table five for John Dory
please thank you but it's not just me
they'll have to impress 20 distinguished
guests will also help me judge both
restaurants dishes including Geale quilo
head chef at the French Embassy and food
writer and novelist Joanne Harris author
of chakra and two popular French
cookbooks both restaurants
front-of-house teams are dining here
today and Collins daddy but they can
only sit and wait while their chefs
battling out you give me a time for the
first table please six or seven minutes
to the pass chef
let's go seven minutes Thank You yelling
wait love the information jean-michel
and Yanni from the galley have made
their names with simple rustic food but
today they're going haute cuisine with
poached John Dory sir with polenta cake
and longest things a lightly battered
oyster and a longer steamed bisque
Oh gasps me so you run one of the best
bistros in the country this doesn't
sound like a bistro classic this sounds
like you we're cooking in your kitchen
today we don't want to do fish to cook
you a trick to race like ever so you're
going you're up there under your Oh to
Professor John Michell turns back ten
years ago in fine dining because he
wanted to become a little bit more
rustic but today he's going back to that
fine dining style and he's really pushed
about what he had for breakfast morning
I don't know it must have been a [ __ ]
strong pot of porridge only hope John
Michell and sous chef Yanni aren't over
stretching themselves winter your fields
for red mullet please me
[Music]
: give me a time please on the first
table one please take a minute suddenly
for fish please three minutes the window
thank you on the other side of the
kitchen calling from Winningham fields
usually has the opposite problem
creating food that's just too fussy
pulling static are exposed because they
haven't got their entourage of 25 chefs
and 15 gardeners and four you know
individuals to wash their cars so today
they are on their own tonight
Colin's pan-fried red mullet and serving
it with a bully based sauce and a
Mediterranean salad
the whole idea about this dish is that
this is this was a salad so each part
has to be perfect and that's what makes
the dish it's not just the flavors and
you can show up you make a chef cause
yet some green beans so it's good okay
how intricate is it on a scale of one to
ten for the garnish is going to be about
seven out of ten the rest of it for Wow
it's not bad for you is it I know yeah
listen it listen it good
deconstructing a Nicoise salad in this
way is a bold move now he's got rid of
all the distracting frills Kaunas gonna
have to really focus on flavors to make
this work
I thought Colleen went again Phil
doesn't go more complicated over the top
yeah he's reined it in he's he's gone
simpler it's a chance to concentrate and
really really show off over at Liguria
the timing of their polenta and deep
fried oyster must be perfect I wonderful
in thought to melt in your mouth when
you having it all those flavor to
disappear in your mouth it's precise
cooking take your place a little bit of
water.that work together just try to
drain that first next time in the clock
and when you dry that fish a little bit
like that when you come to sauce it the
source filets and stick exactly that
yeah great what's your sauce on there
over the place I thought it up as they
played up the pressure was clearly taken
its toll
well he's the sauce on the plate like
these shaking hands of the Queen it's
going all over the place it's a shame
because he looks nervous which I didn't
expect
especially from a French man so the
worst are too shaken to be shaking my
life even when I got married there was
the shaking you know pretty girl made me
shake you that's incredible
- ready wait move it I'll get the
oysters then you start playin a few
leadership that's absolutely beautiful
chef you're perfect in Jean Michels hour
of need I'm delighted to see that
sous-chef Yanni is stepping up to the
plate again I love the way you're
tasting as well yes yeah what you're
tasting yes is what they're eating yes
let's go go last table now please yeah -
John Dory away double three please fish
good to go
all right look good to go please beers
good to go
I spill John Michell and Yanni are
really working as a team sending out
plate after plate of exquisite looking
food John Michell they look great
fantastic
very nice go please no time to the plate
well then actually go teleport base go
good good
in a dish from Nigeria poached John Dory
and langoustine cake poster beignet on
top and a lobster bisque off the John
Dory table for four more way please on
Table five yes he never mentioned go
guys pay Jesse Colin's gone for a simple
dish
so he's cooking must rely on flavors not
frills and I'm not sure he's nailed it
before he passed that it tastes it in
fragrant like oh like bouillabaisse
those almost like his blasted fishing us
has done more veggies want it to taste
or what's on that off fish exactly like
it today they have to make sure that
dish is all about flavor not how things
look starving how long please
ten seconds fish their second you work
together come on guys jelly check your
plates
wait what together work together work
together yeah vibrant colors love the
idea of the egg yolk on there let's go
good happy those Colleen Lygia
yeah they look fantastic go table one
please go beautiful I love that level of
creativity and the confidence to be that
simple without red mullet brilliant last
out we just make it look absolutely
perfect like the first hello yes okay
great Table 3 please let's go that's how
you say so thank you very much for this
Lubbock collie get over every one of
your dishes yes good okay thank you good
excellent okay
your family pan-fried red mullet you
have tomato fondue courgettes I finished
with potato galette on top
Collins presentation is brilliant and
not expect nothing less but I hope his
dish is as successful as leggings
[Music]
service is over and it's time to find
out which of these two incredible dishes
my guests preferred starting with
Winningham fields nice I see now let's
talk fish and what do you think of sauce
also exactly summertime and yeah it's
really simple and I really like it I
thought the red mullet was absolutely
fantastic the skin was really nice and
crispy and it was still very fresh and
hot from the fan it was like being in
the Mediterranean you know on a sunny
day sunshine I'm gonna play the fish was
slightly undercooked for me but overall
it's a really good dish ladies let's
talk John Dory how was it well I think
it was very nice just the whole balance
of the dish was beautiful each other we
all found I think that the oyster was a
slightly odd thing because we couldn't
quite tell what it was
interesting Johnny dory I loved the love
the fish and really delighted by the
oyster I thought that was a real treat
[Music]
both French teams have excelled
themselves in my kitchen serving up
exquisite food worthy of their
reputations and mine think to go through
the semi-finals would be would be
excellent for the restaurant for
everyone back in Edinburgh all the staff
we've worked that I think it would be a
a dream come true for us all
where's Sheila the printers are thinking
and then we take it from there I was
happy with everything we went out there
was nothing I wasn't happy with each
individual part was cooked I wanted to
be cooked so everything went out I'm
happy now I must decide which team has
that all-important genesee quark to take
them through to the semi-final
the chefs from my top two French
restaurants Colin from winter gum fields
in Lincolnshire and John Michell from
legaia in Edinburgh have just finished
the service of their lives two
exceptional restaurants but only one can
stay in the competition
to help me choose I'm gonna taste each
team's dish visually both dishes look
attractive great finesse so the great
first this guys surprised me today
polenta
lined inside with longest steamed
ambitious and dangerous hmm tastes very
good John Dory sauce is delicious
rich robust and a really nice sort of
shellfish bisque really good doesn't
need the oyster try to the end not
really no and the sauce is the is the
key there I love the heart true friends
passion all over that plate we're doin
fields
red mullet crisp in here as they cut
across beautiful
hmm delicious packed full of flavor
the intriguing part there is the sauce
it's like a sort of tomato bouillabaisse
bisque very clever and it looks
intricate it is very very simple
and bloody delicious this is a tough
call because it really surprised me and
I'm more surprised John Michell because
I didn't think he had the capabilities
of doing that and I didn't think that
Colin could rein it in
[Music]
- outstanding French restaurants but
only one can win a place in the
semi-finals
[Music]
okay the winner today is based on
everything we've experienced Colin you
pulled it back you sort of reined it in
which I didn't expect to see today that
dish delicious Lego eek
excelling is difficult under pressure
but you push the boat out
think of the journey and we started off
with 30 dinars turning up unexpectedly
for any restaurant anywhere in the
country that is immense pressure I mean
really immense pressure both restaurants
handled it brilliantly well after that I
then secretly filmed your restaurants in
operation unknown to any of you to make
sure that you weren't just rolling out
the red carpet because it was me
and that told me a lot
so based on everything I've seen
everything I've eaten and everything I
experienced the winner is going to come
down to this the restaurant that I want
to go back to is it that a Gary there
that French charm that real come in sit
in my front room with an ambiance that
is electric or is it the sumptuous
restaurant with rooms that you walk in
and you're sort of blown away with that
charm
tough the winner of the French category
[Music]
it's windier Enfield's congratulations
John Michell you surprised me today and
you are a credit not just to your
restaurant but to your country because
you showed flashes of brilliance don't
stop well done
like am I gonna be disappointed but at
the same time very pleased with what
we've done today we just take it back
did I get easy and pick it from there
[Applause]
great result for us which I'm really
chuffed to bits with Gordon Ramsay one
of the most famous chefs in the world
telling me that you know he likes my
food and he was to go back to my
restaurant so yeah
Wow big to get on top of that you know
it's fabulous so yeah we really really
were really just a bit
[Music]
wynton of fields forever I've been on
the most amazing journey of these two
French restaurants I was quite sad to
say goodbye to the Gehrig
however the journey starts now for
whinging fields they so deserve their
place in the semi-final